so l magazine features kamala harris in
their culture section
and this is what your friends in the
media do and they are not interested in
putting kamala harris in their politics
section she's in their culture section
you see because culture is always
upstream of politics
and they have this long puff piece about
kamal harris here's how this puff piece
starts
because it's wonderful here's how this
pup starts ready here we go
senator kamal harris started her life's
work young
she laughs from her gut the way you
would with family
okay have you ever heard kamala harris
laugh um
she laughs from her gut the way you
would with family if you were then going
to
you know bomb gotham city as she
remembers being wheeled through an
oakland california civil rights march in
a stroller with no straps with her
parents and her uncle
at some point she fell from the stroller
few safety regulations existed for
children's equipment back then
and the adults caught up in the rapture
of protest just kept on marching
by the time they noticed little kamala
was gone and doubled back she was
understandably upset
my mother tells the story about how i'm
fussing harrah says and she's like baby
what do you want what do you need
and i just looked at her and i said
freedom
this is what common hair says okay so
first of all to start a story that way
is the dumbest thing i have ever heard
in my entire life
okay if if your story your political
story begins when you're a toddler who
fell out of a stroller
even if that story happened to be true
which it's not as we'll get to in just a
moment
that is a weird weird take when this is
like one of those twitter takes people
like
my seven-year-old daughter came in the
room and she asked me mommy
why is the gender wage gap so wide when
we've taken so many steps to alleviate
the gender wage gap through federal
legislation
and i looked at her and i cried it's one
of those twitter stories
hey where i fell out of the stroller and
then my mommy looked at me and said what
do you mean i said
freedom by the way in the story it is
spelled f-w-e-e-d-o-m
freedom now there is a one problem
with this story aside from the fact that
it is really really ridiculous
it also happens to be lifted directly
from martin luther king jr
so it turns out that plagiarism
apparently runs throughout like if you
get within
a certain distance from joe biden the
plagiarism is contagious it's like covet
except plagiarism
you start sort of plagiarizing things
and this is elizabeth warren type stuff
she's just taking other people's
personal stories and making them her own
right but that's that's okay right it's
her truth here is a an interview
from a 1965 playboy with martin luther
king by alex haley right the guy who
wrote roots
hey you ready for this here it is i will
never forget a moment in birmingham
when a white policeman accosted a little
negro girl seven or eight years old
who's walking in a demonstration with
her mother
what do you want the policeman asked her
roughly and the little girl looked him
straight in the eye and answered
freedom she couldn't even pronounce it
but she knew
it was beautiful so kamala harris
maybe it's the same girl maybe it was
kamala harris that little girl was me
says kamala harris maybe it was kamala
harris or maybe politicians are the
worst sort of skunks
and they lie to you continually and they
are ridiculous and when the media act
credulous with regard to democrats
but absolutely critical with regard to
republicans they undercut themselves
when the media prints interviews like
the one that elle did with comment
but by the way i'm sure kamala harris
has told that story a million times i'm
sure that she trotted it out over and
people today were saying well did she
think she was gonna get away with it
well yeah
why wouldn't she seriously why wouldn't
she it took until now for anybody to
fact check her story
if you're a democrat the most beautiful
thing about being a democrat is that
elizabeth warren can lie for three
decades about being native american
and it's only when republicans are like
oh yeah by the way she's not
native american that that becomes a real
story for her remember republicans
brought that up in her original senate
race in massachusetts
and the media were like you can't say
that about elizabeth warren she has high
cheekbones
so if you're a democrat of course the
incentive is for you to make up the most
dramatic
possible stories in which you're a
four-year-old and you're telling cops
that you need freedom
absolutely insane and ridiculous but i
think it puts us in minds of where we
stand
in politics and again don't seek higher
values in your politicians you're not
gonna find them there by the way check
out matt walsh's show today uh he's
gonna give his take on that story he'll
also be discussing white musicians who
declined grammy nominations because
they're white and also busy phillips
is this actress i guess and she posted
about her non-binary 12 year old child
weird
how many members of the hollywood
community who are very very warm for the
particular ideology of children who then
fit particularly squarely
within this ideology strange strange
okay so that is your kamala harris
starter for the morning that's just the
appetizer gang
facts don't care about your feelings and
it's a fact that the ben shapiro show is
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content